there's two things it's either you're
scared to fail in front of anybody like
you don't want her to think you're a
failure you don't want your mom dad
brother that's one thing and the second
thing is a lot of people don't do it
because they're scared to lose the money
attention is the number one asset I've
been talking about starting a
construction business for years and some
fear just just doesn't leave me get to a
place where if you need 10 or $20,000 to
start it make pretend in your head
convince yourself that it's 100% going
to go to zero treat it like you're
taking the family on a vacation that
you're going to do it and it's 100%
going to go to zero that has worked for
a lot of people to eliminate the fear
they no longer fear losing that money
they view it as a vacation or as going
out gambling one night or or buying
clothes or a car and when you don't put
that energy on it like you can't lose it
it changes the relationship and
eliminates the
fear